هاني ضعنا بدايه في اخر التطورات
الميدانيه وعمليات القصف
والاشتباكات نعم نبدا من مدينه غزه حيث
قبل قليل سمعت اصوات انفجارات ناجمه عن
عدد من الغارات الجويه في الناحيه
الجنوبيه من المدينه حسب شهود العيان وفي
ساعات مساء امس ايضا كانت هناك عدد من
الغارات في منطقه تل الهواء طالت مناطقه
زراعيه واقعه في المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه
تحديدا كما سفن في منطقه تل الهواء ومنطقه
الشيخ عجلين في المنطقه الوسطى من قطاع
غزه هناك عمليه قصف مدفعي في المناطق
الشرقيه والشماليه من هذه المحافظه فضلا
عن ذلك كانت هناك حاله من الهدوء النسبي
منذ ساعات الصباح لكن كانت في المقابل
حالات غرق كثيره لعشرات خيام الاواء كما
اسلف الزميل اشرف ابو عمره في تقرير له من
المنطقه الوسطى واظهر بشكل واضح هذه الح
الحالات والاوضاع القاسيه التي انطلت
تماما على معظم خيام اللواء وسكان المنازل
المدمره من شمالي قطع غزه حتى جنوبهم وهنا
في رفح ايضا اوضاعا قاسيه عاشها النازحون
هنا في المنطقه الغربيه لرفح وكذلك
المنطقه الوسطى والشرقيه التي امتلات
تماما بعشرات الاف النازحين كذلك خانيونس
التي تعيش اوضاعا استثنائيا بفعل تركز
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه منذ عده
ايام من في الناحيه الغربيه للمدينه و
اتساعها شيئا فشيئا على وقع استمرار
عمليات القصف المدفعي والجوي وكذلك من
الدبابات والاشتباكات العنيفه في الساعات
الاخيره كان هناك هدوءا نسبيا في المنطقه
الغربيه لخان يونس لكن قبل اكثر من ساعتين
من الان كانت هناك سلسله من الغارات
الجويه التي طالت منطقه البلد والمنطقه
الشرقيه ومنطقه حي الامل عشره من الشهداء
على القل على الاقل منذ ساعات الصباح
وصلوا المشفى الاوروبي كذلك مجمع ناصر
الطبي ووفق معلومات وصل وصلت الينا هناك
عدد اخر ما زالوا ملقين على الارض في
منطقه مخيم خان يونس وحي الامل لم تستطع
سيارات الاسعاف او حتى المواطنين من
الوصول الى هذه المناطق بفعل وجود اليات
عسكريه اسرائيليه وانتشار وحدات القناصه
فوق البنايات السكنيه في منطقه مخيم خان
يونس وحي الامل هناك ايضا عشرات الاف
النازحين يعيشون اوضاعا صعبه جدا في مراكز
الايواء التي تحيط بمجمع ناصر الطبي من
الناحيه الشماليه والناحيه الغربيه وكذلك
الناحيه الشرقيه والناحيه الجنوبيه هي
مناطق تمتلئ بالنازحين ولم يستطع سوى
القليل منهم من المغادره وسط
اجراءات قمعيه وسط اجراءات معقده وسط
اجراءات قاسيه في ظل هذا البرد القارص
وعدم سماح القوات الاسرائيليه سوى لاعداد
معينه تشمل في المعظم النساء والاطفال
بالمغادره عبر محور منطقه المعسكر الغربي
والتوجه الى ساحل البحر عبر هذه المنطقه
في ضل البرد القارص وال امطار الغزيره
هناك ايضا كما افدنا وجود مئات من
المعتقلين معظمهم كانوا من النساء من
الاطفال عفوا والفتيه والرجال من قبل
القوات الاسرائيليه تم اقتياد هؤلاء الى
جهه مجهوله وايضا هذه المنطقه تشهد تمركز
كبير للدبابات التي تحاول تطويق مخيم
خانيونس ومنطقه حي الامل هناك ايضا اطر
بعضا من المواطنين الى دفن جثامين الشهداء
في منطقه حي الامل في فناء بعض المنازل
وبعض المتنزهات الصغير وب هذه الحاله
الميدانيه الصعبه جدا هناك يعني ترافق
ايضا وتزامن مع حاله انسانيه سيئه جدا
بسبب الاعداد الكبيره وبسبب صعوبه الاحوال
الجويه الماطره كيف تبدو هذه الليله على
النازحين بكل تاكيد ليلى قاصيه يعيشها
الفلسطينيون هنا مع اشتداد البرد القارص
واستم رار الحاله الجويه المضطربه التي
تشمل هطولا كبيرا للامطار وايضا اجواء
مسحوبه بالاجواء البارده جدا عندما هطلت
الامطار في ساعات الصباح كانت هناك حالات
من الغرق وخروج من الخيام من قبل النازحين
خاصه في المناطق المنخفضه التي تعرضت بشكل
كبير لسيول الامطار وهناك تحذيرات جديه في
الساعات القادمه من عوده هطول الامطار
بشكل كبير واشتداد البرد وهذا ينعكس سلبا
على حياه هؤلاء نازحين وهناك تحذيرات جديه
من قبل وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه فيما يتعلق
بهذا الجانب تحديدا وامكانيه وفاه بعضا من
الاطفال حدثي الولاده والمرضى الذين
يقتنون في هذه الخيام سيما ان معظم هذه
الخيام هي خيام مهترئه وخيام حتى لا تصلح
للعيش لكن يعني نوعا ما تاوي هؤلاء من عدم
المبيت في الطرقات لان البدائل منعدمه
تماما هنا في مدينه رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه
وكل من يصل الى هذه المدينه لا يج جد ماو
له وبالتالي عشرات الاسر الفلسطينيه في
الساعات الاخيره وصلت الى رفح من خان يونس
هي الان تبيت في الطرقات وعلى جنبات يعني
هذه المخيمات التي تتسع وفي كل يوم يمر
على المدينه هنا في رفح تحديدا تزداد خيام
الاواء ويتم فتح مراكز جديده وهؤلاء ياتون
في ظروف صعبه لا يحملون سوى امتعه محدوده
جدا ويسيرون على الاقل خمسه كيلومترات من
خان يونس وصولا الى المنطقه الغربيه
لمدينه رفح جنوبيه قطاع غزه وهم حتى
يفتقرون الى ادنى مقاومات الحياه والرعايه
الصحيه والمتابعه لان هؤلاء بحاجه يعني
لمتابعه وعلاج لان معظم هؤلاء قد اصيبوا
بامراض موسميه وقد تفشت هذه الامراض في
هذه المراكز وايضا انعدام النظافه الشخصيه
وحتى النظافه في هذه المناطق والتلوث
ارتفع بشكل كبير في كافه المكونات في هذا
يعني الظرف الصعب الذي يعني يمر به هؤلاء
في داخل هذه الخيام شكرا جزيلا لك من رفح
راسلنا هاني
الشاعر